ni chez nous nous sommes dans les
bureaux du module des cyber enquête du
spvm
c'est dans ce lieu que son traité les
plaintes reçues à la police de montréal
tous ces postes de travail serve à des
enquêteurs et des programmeurs analystes
pour analyser les menaces de tous genres
quelle que soit leur provenance en ligne
on va demander notre support 24h sur 24
7 jours sur 7 pour tout ce qui est
réseaux sociaux internet applications
mobiles maillant alliés et celle qui
supervise toutes les enquêtes
son équipe n'a pas chômé avec 940
dossiers qui ont été traités depuis
janvier dernier la sergente détective
estime que la charge de travail de son
module a augmenté de 35% par rapport à
on va demander notre expertise pour
faire une localisation d'une personne
pour identifier une personne pourra les
sauvegardes et de la preuve extraire de
la preuve faire des démarches auprès des
réseaux sociaux par exemple en urgence
ou avec des autorisations judiciaires
la grande majorité des menaces sont
faites entre des internautes eux mêmes
ce que je veux dire à la population
c'est que une fois que tu as mis ou tu
as pris la décision de t'asseoir
derrière ton écran et d'écrire quelque
chose dans ton clavier et de laisser
partir sa sur la toile alors tu perds le
contrôle de tous de cette information là
et tu pars aussi le contrôle de ton
identité mais les personnalités
publiques demeurent les cibles les plus
faciles sur les réseaux sociaux
encore hier un autre individu était
formellement accusé de menaces de mort
envers la mairesse de montréal s'en
prendre à l'intégrité physique d'une
personne ou de sa famille c'est c'est
petit et je trouve pas que c'est
acceptable dans une démocratie comme la
non la sûreté du québec est également
fort occupée par les dossiers de menaces
en ligne
les dernières données démontrent que les
cyber enquêtes ont plus que doublé sur
l'ensemble du territoire de la hesse qu
en un an seulement la situation et cite
le directeur aux poursuites criminelles
et pénales a rappelé les conséquences
liées à des accusations criminelles pour
des menaces important de rappeler
justement les menaces qui sont
transmises de cette façon là ne sont pas
prises à la légère
et lorsqu'on personnes ou derrière un
écran le même impact l'aube les mêmes
conséquences n'avançons sont possibles
c'est un geste écrit et criminel la
sergente détective demande donc aux
victimes de menaces en ligne de ne pas
hésiter à contacter la police
quand il nous donne cette information là
on est capable d'aller chercher
l'auteur de ces de ces genres de propos
l'anonymat n'existe pas dans l'univers
numérique ici pascal robidas radio
canada montréal